[Music]
a man was caught at the virginia airport
trying to bring 23 weapons in his
carry-on luggage
let me let me tell you the list he's
like they don't check the carry-on all
right how about we guess can we guess
okay go ahead yeah all right nunchucks
nunchucks yeah
spear butterfly knife
can you just give us a simple yes c4 so
far none of this i don't think it is a
foldaway ar which by the way i mean dude
you could basically kill everyone in the
world with that they're almost all
knives by the way okay oh really
a klingon bailiff okay yeah you got it
let me tell you what they are
there's nine
nine disposable scalpels eight folding
blade knives three throwing knives a
dagger a switchblade and a set of brass
knuckles wait three throwing knives this
will have throwing knives not even ton
fuzz around there dude is he a knife
salesman dude just sell the throwing
knife where you're at and then buy
authority
stupid ass stupid idiot
can't you check there it is lost and
swap me holy [ __ ] you can probably check
those yeah
you can check those doesn't it look like
it that's a throw knife huh
three wait does these sell them oh this
is this is a zinfandel it's only not the
same as a kunai knife is he a nice guy
yeah he's a knife guy for sure and he's
like i have needles from one of the
rings and we're like yeah great
guess who doesn't want to [ __ ] you women
that's like all my dick too did you say
needles needle is from game of thrones
one of the rings bro no lord is a sting
bro no it's called a needle it glows
blue wow this guy doesn't [ __ ] know
he doesn't know it's lord of the rings
huh
you know because i don't get real
anything we just fact check you live it
says it's illegal i'm pretty sure it's a
game of thrones
all right well here's something yeah i'm
getting [ __ ]
yeah i get [ __ ] i know what needle is
every one of these things if they were
in his checked back would have been
perfectly okay oh really is that right
yeah hella true i bought a knife in
hawaii and they said look make sure you
check it and you're all good but i
thought brass knuckles weren't even
allowed at all anyway yeah brass
knuckles depends on the state oh god
does that mean does that mean you try to
bring it through tsa or you already went
past tsa with it you tried to bring it
through tsa yeah
do you think when his [ __ ] got stuck
he's like
[Laughter]
what's going on the [ __ ] wow great yeah
what are you guys doing
he's like what do i have a big
toothpaste huh what's going on he's like
i pull my laptop out what do you want
from me and what's the point of the
foldable knife like you why you need
more than one
you know what i mean like
you gotta [ __ ] do it like this every
single time too i know what you have to
be throwing those because you got to go
get them
yeah and three is a good number maybe he
went to like one of those like
gun and knife shows and just bought a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah that could be like
random check my ass
yeah it could be one of those guys i
wish there was more information on the
guy
but basically he was issued a citation
he was um he was asked to check them
but instead he just abandoned all of
them and said whatever the [ __ ] i don't
care and then was allowed on his flight
that is so ridic he was asked to check
that means they're already giving him a
chance dude i get it though checking
luggage is a nightmare
it takes tickets take [ __ ] 25 minutes
and they're like waiting yeah it's
reasonable that they ask them and they
always lose your luggage what if their
lives get into the wrong hands you're
like god damn i'm gonna [ __ ] go away
and you're like i don't know which one
it is does anybody know which one it is
i don't [ __ ] know which one is this
23 dimes here's a dump thing i remember
oh here's the dump thing well yeah
because this is something that happened
to me and i've always thought this was
so stupid and unfair um so you see the
size of this [ __ ] right here no way
i had a necklace this size of like a
rifle
this size
and they said no guns no way i swear to
god i said no guns a lot i was going
through tsa
the lady said the tsa lady said um
yeah you you can't have that here and i
said okay cool uh that's kind of weird
but all right i started doing this and
she goes
get your hands off of it and she goes
get the [ __ ] on the floor right
and spread your butt cheeks
she'll take the clip out and then lapd
shot you 81 times
i go i go dude it's cool like i'll just
leave it here and she goes
no me and you are going outside of the
airport
and i'm gonna watch you throw that in
the trash dude the tsa lady before she
saw you walk in she goes hey watch watch
watch i'ma [ __ ] with this guy check this
out check out filipinos all filipinos do
this watch
no show we walked she tricked me she
took me out of the line we walked out to
the front of lax like where the drop
offs aren't [ __ ]
and she made me take it off and put it
in that trash can that's a power trip
yeah that's a power shift though i don't
even think that's protocol a gun this
size it wasn't it was just like like do
you remember exactly what she said was
she ever like we're gonna go on a little
quest outside
you
and after you did that she put on a
jabberwocky's face mask and went back to
work i just remembered that every time i
wanted a laugh because i thought it was
so absurd she was like you're gonna
laugh are you gonna laugh like she
wanted me to like to laugh because she
was like you can be arrested you can be
arrested right now
is that funny do you want to laugh at
that do you know how many babies die
you're swallowing these things
no because this was still 2000 2009. oh
right after that [ __ ] went down after
what [ __ ] 2009 2002 whoa
but it's still like it's still this size
and i was just like imagine she sees
that she's like that belongs in the
runway
all right what are you doing with that
sir how the [ __ ] did you get that off
it's the captain with the plane
how the [ __ ] did you get off the tarmac
that [ __ ] started going like beep beep
beep [ __ ] she switches jobs
holy [ __ ]
dude imagine joe gets a time machine and
he's like he's like take me back to
september 11 2002.
[Laughter]
everyone just it's going to happen
everybody loves what's happening like
wow this sick [ __ ] wow dude people just
died last year what the [ __ ]
you sick bastard you sick [ __ ]
he's going back in time to fix it he's
like taking it back to september 10th
2002
tomorrow it's gonna be horrible you'll
see there was like this sick bastard
they're like it's gonna happen again why
[ __ ] i messed up the flux capacitor 2002
what if you didn't remember the day that
sucks
that's almost
yeah they did the they did the same
thing to one of my crewmates for having
a he had like a tokidoki hoodie and on
those the zipper looks like a bullet
the zipper oh and they and they made him
detach it and do the same thing oh i did
i did the same thing with my do you
remember collusive we had a bullet uh
necklace as well and the same thing
happened same thing yeah but i get a
bullet a bullet at that size it's like a
bullet but a rifle that makes more
actual bullet yeah but if you're looking
at a little ass gun yeah you never
decided to say let me talk to your
superior this no every time i even kind
of open my mouth they were warning me
that it could be a lot worse than this
so they were just like yeah she was just
like don't don't like always like that
it was like any time i was like even if
i smirked she was like you're gonna
laugh you're gonna laugh i'm sure you're
white lady yeah she was yeah she's
she looked like [ __ ] uh zena's
sidekick
gabrielle gabriel very hot very hot very
lazy
very busty i like the busty
i only remember [ __ ] lucy lawless and
i remember the one
one of the specific things she told me
was that i was like i was like it's not
a gun and then she goes
no replica weapons allowed replica
weapons i was like so if i go like this
sorry okay well sir put that away where
did that come from throw that away right
now if they [ __ ] inconvenience me
like that i just be like i don't i don't
know i didn't get to go back in line
either to where i was what yeah i was at
the front you got to start back oh my
god [ __ ] i don't know it's like
you're a second place citizen
oh my god she didn't have to deal with
that now i know how it feels
yeah it was really welcome to the club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you